with the releases of drake and kanye's
new albums talk of the two men's ongoing
feud have taken over social media but to
be honest there are some much more
interesting beefs and clapbacks that
happened last week and we'd love to
highlight them in a segment called
last week during a white house press
conference reporter owen jensen
questioned white house press secretary
jenn saki about president joe biden's
support for abortion rights here was the
exchange why does the president support
abortion when his own catholic faith
teaches abortion is morally wrong
he believes that it's a woman's right
it's a woman's body and it's her
choice who does he believe then should
look out for the unborn child he
believes that it's up to a woman to make
those decisions and up to a woman to
make those decisions with her doctor i
know you've never faced those choices
nor have you ever been pregnant but for
women out there who have faced those
choices this is an incredibly difficult
thing president believes their rights
should be respected go ahead i think we
got to move on
i think we have to move on you've had
plenty of time today go ahead
she puts your ass on timeout and i'm not
talking about the magazines oh
oh saki sake now oh
you should have avoided that question
it's a woman's right to choose and she
chose to shut you though
conservative author and hardcore
anti-vaxxer candace owens requested a
cova test recently from a testing
facility in aspen colorado the facility
denied her request and the ceo sent her
a letter that said
we cannot support anyone who has
proactively worked to make this pandemic
worse by spreading misinformation
politicizing and discouraging the
wearing of masks and actively dissuading
people from receiving life-saving
vaccinations
[Applause]
that's the negative on that covet test
as in you ain't getting one
kansas owens nah more like kansas no one
[Applause]
[Applause]
a month after the tokyo olympics the
best gymnast in the history of life
simone biles took to instagram this week
to reflect on her experience at this
year's games she wrote i've pushed
through so much the past couple years
the word quitter is not in my vocabulary
for some of you that may be how you
define me but keep talking because i
can't hear you over my seven olympic
medals
[Applause]
she said i'm still not a quitter but you
still a hater oh
the competition is uneven no bars
she stuffed the landing right on your
head
she got bronze silver and gold while you
got paper or plastic
despite several recent climate
emergencies house and senate republicans
said this month that switching to wind
solar and other clean energy sources
would damage our economy the earth had
this to say in response
look at that tornado
damn
i just said i got your damage right here
um
amber
this one kind of affects all of us yes
it's a little too soon i'm still like
putting water back into my toilet
right like there was literally a tornado
in new jersey yeah a tornado
wow
i guess you're right
that tornado really was
a twist
this has been
[Applause]
[Music]
you